hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2022 British Science
Fiction and thriller movie called blank
which follows the story of a fiction
books author who takes a short escape to
cure her writer's block but then things
go wrong
Claire is a renowned and award-winning
fiction books author
she has written a lot of famous books
and has appeared on the cover of several
magazines because of her Masterpiece
it's common for some authors that at
some point they'll get stuck to find new
ideas and this also happens to Claire
she is forced by the Publishers to
submit her work within one month
few days have passed but Claire still
doesn't even manage to complete the
first page of the book while she must
pay the overdue expenses
she then receives an offer from The
Retreat an organization providing a new
environment for living
Claire accepts the invitation hoping
that she'll find fresh ideas there long
story short Claire arrives at The
Retreat she enters the house and is
welcomed by a virtual concierge named
Henry he explains the unit's doors and
windows have been reinforced to block
out all exterior noises creating a very
quiet environment he tells her that
she'll be accompanied by an AI personal
assistant Rita for the next 30 days
Henry guarantees her safety because her
personal assistant is capable of dealing
with all types of houseworks and medical
emergencies the next morning she's
awakened by Henry who asks Claire about
her preferred breakfast menu while
having breakfast she conversates with
Rita to make sure that she's a real
robot feeling better Claire is ready to
continue her work she takes out his
typewriter but suddenly Henry appears
telling her that he has prepared a
device to increase neurological activity
she puts on the device but later decides
not to use it as a result she becomes
worried and couldn't type a single word
realizing that she's not progressing at
all Henry shows up again to offer some
help but she rejects it in the middle of
the night Claire wakes up in the living
room and sees Rita's sleep sitting not
responding to her at all the next day
she thinks Rita was charging last night
but the robot claims that she has a
battery life of approximately 50 years
Claire returns to her work desk but
she's still stuck several weeks have
passed and Claire begins to get bored
with the same routines every day without
having any significant progress in her
work someday during her morning run she
finds out that the house is fully
powered by solar panels and is located
far from the city soon she becomes
frustrated and feels lonely she even
asks the virtual concierge to drink with
her one night The house's system is
attacked by unknown malware causing Rita
to malfunction Henry tells her that he
must reboot the system meaning that
Henry will be unavailable for a moment
Claire then goes to the living rooms and
finds Rita who suddenly becomes more
aggressive in the morning Claire is
unable to unlock the door for some
reason
Rita tells her that her keyprint has
been erased from the system and now only
the robot is authorized to open the door
Claire then orders the AI robot to open
the door but she refuses unless Claire
has finished her work Claire insists and
attempts to attack the personal
assistant but Rita hurts her instead
shortly after Henry appears again
telling her that the unit is fully AI
operated and until the issue is resolved
Rita has full control of the house he
adds that the internal communication is
also breached so contacting people
outside the house is not possible left
with no option Claire tries to break the
windows but they're unbreakable to make
things worse Reed also shows a
malfunction sign the robot does not even
remember injuring Claire's hand
Claire eventually realizes that to leave
the house she must finish her work as
soon as possible
she begins typing all day and all night
until the script is finished
she then hands the scripts to Rita read
it as a quick screen throughout the
paper finding out that Claire has
plagiarized another author's work so
she's still not allowed to leave Claire
then attempts to activate the car alarm
but Rita ensures that nobody's living
nearby the unit that night Rita informs
her that she has detected vital signs
she screams for help but turns out it's
just a fox days pass Claire becomes more
stressed out she asks Henry to find
another escape plan but the windows in
the main doors are the only ways in and
out still not giving up Claire tries to
trigger the fire alarm hoping that the
system will shift to emergency protocol
but she later passes out due to lack of
oxygen
at this moment Claire becomes hopeless
and doesn't know what to do anymore she
asks Henry whether the guests on the
other unit are trapped as well but he
has no access to that information he
adds that all guests data were deleted
during the breach meaning that no one
knows Claire is there she finally puts
on the device continues working on her
paper and gets inspired by the vision
she sees through the device The Story
begins with a girl whose identity is not
yet revealed and she is forced to live
with her rude mother Helen the mother is
blind and she tries her best to treat
her mother unfortunately she keeps being
accused of putting poison in her
mother's food even though they're
actually medicines turns out Helen is
also an author and her daughter helps
her by typing it on the typewriter
however her works are always rejected by
the companies in the middle of her work
Claire gets distracted by Rita several
times
she tells the AI robot that she still
cannot figure out the ending of the
story to her surprise Rita gives her
some ideas and insights suggesting she
had more drama in the story
still that night Claire summons Henry
who seems unresponsive he reveals that
his system was attacked as well causing
his algorithm depleting gradually Claire
seems frustrated but nothing much she
can do about it back to Claire's story
Helen's script is finally accepted by
one of the publishers
since that day they have been eagerly
refining the script in the morning
Claire attempts to find a way so she can
get out but Rita is still strict to the
protocol installed into her she then
desperately states that she's been in
the unit for almost two months and the
food reserves are running low but the AI
robot doesn't care at all because she
has no feelings needing someone to talk
to that night Claire tells Rita about
her background she tells her about how
people always wanted more and more from
her until she had run out of stories
even at the highest level of her career
if she stops producing new stories no
one can ever guarantee her future this
fact makes her suffer every night so she
drinks to calm herself down however Rita
senses that Claire has reached dangerous
levels of alcohol poisoning thus she
pours the remaining wine into the sink
this action makes her out of control and
starts messing around the next day
Claire decides to end her story in the
worst way for unknown reason she writes
that Helen attempts to kill her own
daughter but she eventually escapes from
the house and never comes back
she then gives Rita the whole script
however the AI robot senses that Claire
is lying and tells her to write the real
ending to The Story one night while Rita
is inactive Claire attempts to open the
door by using Rita's fingerprint but
it's unsuccessful as it only works when
Rita is operating
Claire almost gives up trying to kill
herself in the bathroom but she's then
rescued by Rita
the next day Claire calls Rita to her
room and asks her to read the script out
loud while she's reading the story
Claire grabs a defibrillator and uses
this opportunity to electrocute the AI
robot however Rita is still functioning
so Claire runs to the kitchen hitting
Rita's head repeatedly until her system
is damaged Rita is finally willing to
open the door but her battery is running
low with her remaining energy she
immediately drags her body towards the
door and uses her Palm to open the door
the door is finally unlocked and Claire
finally is able to breathe fresh air
it's then revealed that Helen's story
was never accepted after finding out
that her daughter is lying she beats her
up so her daughter decides to escape
from the house
sometimes later the daughter returns to
the house only to find that her mother
has committed suicide she goes upstairs
and unlocks Helen's box which contains
two scripts inside it she subsequently
leaves the house and the stories
eventually become Claire's best seller
books
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching